Jeffrey and I we were working with a
vocal track for tenth music so we knew
we wanted to have the score be human
voices and then we were at Zuni one day
right and we saw Bobby
and we thought Bobby Eureka and wrote
him a letter and he said yes that's how
he had never done score before he put
together voices drew for the film and
then they went on tour after the film
terms of Dustin Hoffman I think we all
discussed get it we wanted someone
unassailably straight to narrate it to
make the country feel comfortable at
that time and we went to Jimmy Stewart
and he passed and then I was working at
sand dollar which was a production
company that was owned by Sandy Gallin
Dolly Parton and the Cystic company was
a management company who managed Barbra
Streisand Dolly Parton Neil Diamond
Michael Jackson the Pointer Sisters all
those people in all their areas of
entertainment threw off per year 300
million dollars in California American
real money managers can't make deals
only agents can make deals by law so we
pushed all our clients to CAA at the
height of my covert psa's CIA anus and
he had an assistant named you know in
other words we were writing a check
every year to my Grove it's for 30
million dollars so Mike had to be very
good to me but he had like 100 other
Schmucks that he had a cater to as well
and I learned how to use those levers of
power and one of the leaders of power
was his assistant Jay Maloney and I
don't know if you remember this but you
sent me a rough cut that was three and a
half hours and I remember I watched it
with Joel Schumacher at one night and he
looked at me and said Howard Oscar time
and I remember thinking to herself Wow
and I remember calling up Jay Maloney
and I said to him I want I need you to
watch this movie because Mike represents
Dustin Hoffman and I want you to get
this rough cut of Dustin Hoffman and so
he did and then the next day I called up
Mike Ovitz and I said I need you to
watch this three-and-a-half hour rough
cut which he did
and the next morning he called me up and
he said this deserves an Oscar Dustin
Hoffman has never done pro bono he's in
London outdoing Death of a Salesman I
will get this to him and the guys went
to him and got him Phil and I went to
London and recorded him and the only
thing he asked for was bananas
remember bananas in the recording studio
for energy right right he was doing a
play so I you never dealt with somebody
that's that prominent and also that busy
when they're doing something you know
pro bono are they just gonna show up and
like you know do it in 20 minutes or are
they gonna actually you know work and
obviously Dustin actually worked and he
did every change that every fix let's
try this let's try that he could not
have been sweeter or more supportive and
somebody I forget who was somebody in
the room and Dustin I think has eight
eight children
something like that and someone said
well if one of your kids was gay you
know would you be okay with it which
again it shows you how long ago it was
because now nobody would think of asking
would that be okay not meant but
somebody asking if he said well of
course I'd be okay as long as you know
they had someone they loved and it was
cool so well so what could piss you off
that your kid could do and he thought
about for a second says they could be a
critic
he allied himself with the quilt and
this project I mean everywhere we went
he was you know and it's very very proud
of his work and still talks about it to
this day